ya know and welcome to this video this
is some about round eight of Tata Steel
a video actually that is necessary
because I forgot one game in my
presentation yesterday um and this is
fun viele against the Nakamura somehow I
forgot this game I don't know why it
wasn't no boring or something I just
forgot it um ok let's go briefly through
this game to have the coverage complete
um we have family playing default as
usual and the Nakamura being a very
versatile in this opening Charles goes
to the bogo Indian which is not played
that often in top-level chest but it
started bad opening black giving this
check and push up d to this is the main
move and now Nakamura place a five this
line and the following moves g3d six
Bishop g2 9bd seven The Sun has become
popular in recent yes it's a quite an
interesting setup for black we see
castles a fine this is the idea Black
has got the bishop out of the pawn chain
and then sets up the pawns on dark
square so you have two scenarios this
Bishop might get exchanged then black
has got a healthy bone structure on
black actually and this happens quite
often in the setup preserves the bishop
and uses his own c4 c5 on in fact white
now plays Bishop e3 which looks a bit
odd at first placing the bishop in front
of the e to pawn but it simply gets out
of the way of the before Bishop so white
um probably sets up a threat of a three
to trap this Bishop like my take on d4
but it lets black basically take on
deform so you want the square for for
the bishop on c5 also takes bishop cakes
too
yet to have a normal set up again not
with the bishop blocking d born and now
black castled a three-wish a bareback
Knight c3 so we see that this will
probably get exchanged at some point and
then black gum as a position with a
slight um space disadvantage but it is
very solid he doesn't have any a bad
piece or long-term strategic color issue
is just got a little bit of um yeah less
space so Knight c3 droopy eight points
to c6 yeah wants to control those class
roop TG 127 or fairly normal age 3m
takes control of the g4 and now an
interesting decision mannequin where I
could play in various ways but he went
95 which actually invite some on a pawn
structure change and this is accepted by
a front villa he took on c5 jack takes
on f3 Bishop takes D takes d5 and Bishop
g2 back edge ruler saying so this what
was what my camera provoked with 95 it's
an interesting transformation of pawn
structure Black has got this double porn
on c6 and c5 and this constitutes both
the weakness and strength the parts
control very important squares
especially the default square by C five
but the Queen side is also somewhat
weakened light a4 for instance would
attack the porn and intend to use the v6
square so black and has potential
weaknesses on the queenside but on the
other hand White's queenside all is also
not ideal he's got this pawn structure
which M is not perfect c4 can be it can
be weak and another features and white
Scott the four against free majority
because of the double bond so why it's
ideal setup would be to push eform f
form and e5 and then based and then 90
46 for the complete dream and becoming
reality so this is what white would like
to do and of course Nakamura is busy to
prevent that we see that he goes to
extreme measures to do this Queenie five
centralizes queen e form and now it's
mentioned if you give why the time he
will play f4e 594 and resins basically
if a night comes to d6 block him yeah
threw the towel through throw the towel
here yeah well he will be m in huge
trouble so what does the camera do to
prevent a form cow g5 and move that I
think nowadays is not so shocking to
most players but I don't know probably
40 50 years ago it would would be a good
come as a huge shock okay it simply
stops a form like would then be able to
take it and he tries to make use of his
dark squares black has got strong dark
square control you must see that eform
has weakened the defrost gram so like
him would like a knight on d4 and also
on e5 but he needed to play g5 to make
all this even possible otherwise why
would play air for so um g5s is
necessary perhaps Queen d2g form yeah it
was again threatened this ebb form so um
we have them further transformation and
in fact all this sum is probably am
better for white it's not quite sure at
least them for me I'm not quite sure how
much better it is but
it looks it looks tricky for black those
weaknesses still count for something
maybe this whole plan with 95 accepting
this pawn structure was a bit a bit too
too risky we see that now the Queen's
come off and like needs to protect c5
and the problem is some that he really
doesn't have any hameau Gnaeus
development going this bishop on c8 is
completely useless okay this is how
isn't a great piece either but c8 is a
problem you always got this idea like
can barely cover all this u5 this
intense to make this Bishop better it
succeeded no this is saying yeah okay
six was to to cover b6 and this position
step by step gets more and more
problematic for black here he needs to
capture basically and now h5 is another
weakness not from F to 43 is another
weakness and in fact me a couple of
moves later at this stage we have
repetition of moves 96 is a little trick
if white would take on c6 then like has
this skewer him need to be cautious in
fact I'm valve Elia repeated moves to
gain a bit of time there should be two
naughty form back back and now Knight c3
of course he avoids the complete
repetition why does some significantly
better ESO no draw brooke a 70 at this
point i think he missed the chance to
maybe an even increases advantage more
but it's
there are various waste for why to get
some some big edge but I actually very
much like the move Bishop a 4 here
because it tries to get rid of the c6
pawn win this pawn and in the process
make this Bishop either great piece on
d5 for example or get it exchanged and
in fact I don't see a movie for black
can try to get covered home for the
moment but then white can simply take if
like would try to attack this rook you
still have f6 and this looks like a
disaster for black after the c6 pawn is
gone they also those usual so probably
this was was an easier way to go but the
way I when really played also looks
looks quite strong this kind of stuff
also should be somewhat better for white
Bishop f4 was was stronger than in this
position Nakamura gets at least some
play check you know he enters on the the
second rank and has some activity with
the rook but it's still rather tricky
hehe took on c4 and this seems to be
inaccurate but difficult difficult to
see um in fact there were alternatives
like bishop oops official e6 or b-five
something like this the problem with
this move is looking a look at this
white now has Bishop g4 and this is
really rather annoying you cannot give a
check anymore on the D file you could
play rock d3 check but now this is not
possible and what should like do if he
moves the bishop let's say for instance
somewhere here then white will push with
f5 and h5 to come and then those pawns
will be very dangerous they are simply
much quicker than blacks queenside pawns
and this is the problem also if
blackwood exchange then there's also
this issue those points are simply
quicker supported by the king and this
should be a very much better for wide
yeah in the game we decided to go here
right gains the temple and now push it
the pawns and this leads to UM big
problems for black again check yeah
white get some to pass pawns and here
after King a g5 you played the move f7
which keeps a big advantage but it's not
easy to see why he didn't take on c6
this is the simple moves of the keeping
the f6 porn and it's yeah I guess it's
pretty much over but not sure what the
bed black should try to defend this
there's still be six also hanging which
would lead to a two-point advantage so
I'm yeah the computer once the player
this move answer the toughest offense
but this is just winning it's similar to
the game it's just a bit a bit more
convincing as the sponsor wives in the
game have a look f7 was played look a
faint white eggs so it's very similar
just the f point is gone and here why
does not so probably very close to
winning but the the other line a simple
some think was a simply quicker ya can't
check here and try to took them yeah 11
annoyances that white cannot cover the
beep on here rook v5s is very bad
because of c3 which wins the tempo and
now the C porn is very dangerous if
maybe black is even better here so I'm
be a big mistake cannot cover the B porn
so wyd simply an abandoned this plaque
and tries to use his sub two passports
for yeah I've got the H porn and the a
pond but still on there are some some
tricks in this position and the fun
thing is that in this position move 6
even really really fell into a into a
bat-trap I think here probably he needs
to go a 5 which is also the computer
choice and the computer gives white are
very huge advantage in fact I continued
this a bit and there some positions
where the computer gives white more than
to pawn advantage but it's still a draw
so it's not entirely easy on pretty
simple to win this but look at the game
this is of course this is just a much
better try the game we played rook c6
which doesn't look so um illogical I
mean it clears the way for the a porn
and keeps an eye on the C porn but the
problem is black has this smooth and
this is actually a double threat threat
is that a four is hanging and Bishop
deewana threatened winning this this
Bishop and yeah what does a wide
supposed to do now you don't really have
a great move yeah so why took on c4 and
then we got this Bishop t1 pinning move
first I think Brooke a form might might
save white with them I mean saving in
terms of winning advantage but the
problem is that black has the
interesting
move rook takes every sacrificing the
exchange and after rook takes a three
push up a form there's really no way to
to save the edge pawn let's have a look
at the problem is white played this move
but if white would try in other ways to
hang on to this pawn let's say you would
start with this route cage-free then
there's King h6 King and form we should
be eight threatening to take it and the
problem is that in this position if
white would try to to get to cover cover
the porn then this check we should be
seven check and it's completely
completely over and what else should
should do I try here if you would stay
the only thing that you need to be
cautious of as if Blaque would take now
there are some nesting to have five and
then you and really it really suits one
what should like like play now you must
give up the special band will she lose
the game so you need to be cautious but
white simply cannot make any progress
with the pawn on the edge farm you would
simply take the pond once the rook gives
the h-bomb so it is a drawn in the game
in fact Luke f6 as mentioned with plate
Bishop to e8 and we fairly quickly got
go to the most josh position of all the
instant rocking against him so I'm a
very narrow escape my Nakamura who
probably was lost at more than one point
and Yemen vini certainly young wasn't
too enthusiastic after this game as he
certainly had big chances to Sky's third
win in
wagon day 2013 yeah thanks for watching
and I'll be back tomorrow with round
nine hopefully then with all seven games
and not like this time with six game and
set then then an add on a day later yeah
thanks for watching bye